Let's go next to Dante from Florida.
So Dante, every time you call in, I have more
detailed notes.
At one point you were for Bernie, then you
called in and you were hardcore Tulsi.
And if I recall correctly, last time you called
in, you were still for Tulsi, but you were
voting Bernie instead or what's going on now?
Well, I've always been a Bernie Sanders supporter.
Um, he's been my number one candidate in the
race before he got in the race officially.
Right.
Um, I support, I defend Tosi Gabbert sometimes
because I think she is running a great campaign
and she doesn't get the credit she deserves
from a lot of people in progressive independent
media.
So there are certain issues yet.
Well she's talking about [inaudible] and so
yeah, so birthdate is my number one candidate,
but I will defend those together.
Got it.
Okay.
So Dante, I want to, I want to hear your question,
but your connection is going in and out.
So let's see if we can resolve and I do want
to hear your question.
Alright.
Is that better?
Yes it is.
All right.
So my question was, um, so Elizabeth Warren,
now that she's running in the democratic primary,
she seems to have a lot of these plans and
ideas, but it, to me it comes off as it, she's
grandstanding because she didn't really have
these plans or ideas just a few years ago
when she was in the Senate.
So I don't, I don't think you, I don't think
a lot of people take that into account.
What's an example of [inaudible] and Dante?
What's an example of something that she's
advocating?
For now, but wasn't a couple of years ago.
Well, like our STEM all it takes,
sorry, sorry.
You're breaking up.
Dante, her stance on what
her position on money in politics.
She's not as against it as she claims to be.
She raised $10 million in big money in his
Senate campaign and she transferred it to
her primary campaign.
Yeah.
But hold on a second.
Dante.
So the train, hold on Dante, we've got to
break these things down and I'm just trying
to struggle through the bad connection here.
Um, the transferring money thing is, I mean,
listen, Bernie transferred money.
It's very common to transfer money from one
campaign to another.
Now you're first assertion but hold on.
Toss.
Big money fundraisers.
Right.
I agree with you.
There is a difference, which is that Elizabeth
Warren has money previously raised from corporate
PACS.
I, you're completely right as far as that
goes.
But is there a policy that she is advocating
for now that she didn't previously is what
I'm trying to understand?
Um, Medicare for all,
I don't think she's really strongly advocating
for it.
I've heard her say, I mean, listen, I've said
Bernie is stronger at Bernie, says the burnt
Medicare for all is the way, uh, people like
Bernie per people like Warren and Tulsi have
kind of danced around it and they've said,
yeah, it sounds good, but like other ideas
are okay too and whatever.
So I, I don't know that she's really changed
on that.
I think she's always been sort of into Medicare
for all, but not seeing it as the way.
Well, no, cause there was an interview when
she was asked, um, after she won her Senate
race, I think it was like in 2013 yeah.
And the interview with, with implying that
she was, she supported Medicare for all and
she set the record straight and she made very
clear that she, she told him to go back and
look at it because she'd never supported Medicare
for all.
And that was back in 2013.
I've never seen that.
But I mean it's also, I mean, people's positions
do evolve, right?
Like I'm sure you would, you would grant,
you know, you like Tulsi Tulsi says, hold
on Dante, hold on.
Dante.
Tulsi says her position on gay rights has
changed radically.
Do you consider that to be a cha?
A genuine change?
Yeah, but there isn't a process and she explained
how she came to that conclusion.
Elizabeth Warren, back in 2016 Bernie Sanders
was running on Medicare for all.
That was the center of his campaign.
He changed the national discuss the national
discourse on health care back in 2016 if she
actually supported Medicare for all, she would've
supported Bernie Sanders.
Hey, I'm with you there.
Listen, I have a video clip on YouTube where
I say, if Elizabeth Warren supported all of
Bernie's ideas in 2016 why didn't she endorse
some during the primary?
So you and I are aligned there.
I just think, Dante, that we want to be a
little more precise in our criticisms because
as I kind of gently prod you with questions,
you're moving the goalposts and sort of making
different arguments and you know, I want next
time you call in, I want you to really be
precise.
Okay?
All right.
Dante, you know, I love you buddy.
Listen, calling, examine what discretion is.
Okay.
Sounds good.
We'll talk again.
Dante, thank you for the call.
Uh, we're going to bump Dante half a point
in our color rating system cause that was
a very, very solid call.